ot good to see you how are you carlos
what's going on man
i'm good hey we all need a mason
everybody needs
someone who's like this dude like the
resourceful guy that can just kind of
get
anything is that the kind of person you
are with your group if they're like oh
we need a car you're like i got you
i got you i'll figure something out well
i wish i needed mason yeah i need i
could actually live with a couple of
masons
uh in my life um but yeah he's the kind
of guy you want around
really i'm wondering
you know we all know about the fate of
natasha in end game
what was what mason's reaction was
they're so close in this movie in black
widow
you want me to cry in the interview and
say only a four minute interview i'm i'm
not going gonna try and kind of distance
myself from that question
obviously it was heartbreaking that you
can see that they've got this connection
this magical connection between them so
yeah it really tore him apart i imagine
is he's a cool guy to have in this film
in this role
but it would be great to see him more i
mean uh do you think we'll have him back
in in further marvel features maybe
other
types of avengers movies listen if you
want to start that petition
i'm here for it let's make it happen you
and canada
together i hope so and i definitely have
space for it um
he's the kind of character that could
turn up and help out
anybody who needed a little bit of
sorting out
it was interesting seeing how you know
all the characters
the character rumor i guess circulation
going on before the film came out
and people trying to place who you were
going to be in the film
and i know it's impossible to talk about
until people get a chance to see the
movie but is there a part of you that's
fine like
yes this is who i play i can finally say
it to you
it's not this character that character
here we are i mean
that's what i was saying and the more i
said it
people were just like oh yeah yeah yeah
you're playing mason are you bro
got it yeah so i was like all right well
i don't know what i can do
[Laughter]
well one role we're very excited to see
you play is of um
as a barack obama it's a hell of a role
to get a chance to play
uh did you get to talk to the man to get
some insight you won't talk to me i
don't know what i've said to him
no it was it was challenging but you
know what in some ways it was good that
i didn't because
that way otherwise you're too reverent
he's already like the most perfect guy
you know you don't be too reverent to
the dude so not talking to him allowed
me to try and like look under the
fingernails a little bit and give a
little bit more of a kind of
nuanced portrayal of the man and maybe
some of his weaknesses and strengths
it's crazy to think about playing a role
of a character who like you said
it's i mean he's like this perfect guy
everybody knows who he is he's still
around and he's going to watch it
he's going to see it right are you are
you interested in finding out what his
feedback is
no not at all i mean because who's going
to be happy with that you know i mean
who's gonna be like my gosh that guy you
know especially when you're like you're
the smart charismatic guy you're always
gonna be disappointed probably you know
so now
you can stay away but i think everyone
else is gonna love them like we've been
filming it it's going so well
viola obviously is fire um
so i think it's going to be a banger to
be honest
that's excellent well i'm looking
forward to that and yeah let's start
that petition
because we got to get mason back then we
can't it can't be just this
we can't no i don't think it will be and
i'm gonna talk to you
you